Can you spot the following pattern if
you look at this grid here and see how
it's been transformed into this grid and
likewise how this grid on the left has
been transformed into this grid Can you
spot that pattern could you in other
words predict what would happen to this
grid here in the test example well it
might shock you to learn that language
models like gp4 can't do this they are
terrible at noticing that the little
squares are being filled in with a
darker shade of blue this specific
abstract reasoning challenge was not in
the training data set of GPT 4 and that
model cannot generalize from what it has
seen to solve the challenge it's not
generally intelligent it's not an
artificial general intelligence now you
might think that's a minor quipple but
it gets to the heart of why current
generation AI is not AGI and frankly
isn't even close and no neither will
this problem be solved by a simple naive
scaling up of our models but this video
isn't just about picking out one floor
orbe it a critical one in our current
llms it's more my attempt to address
this swirling debate about whether AI is
overhyped or underhyped for many AI is
nothing but hype and is a giant bubble
while for others AGI has already arrived
or is just months away but you don't
need an opinion what does the evidence
show this video will draw upon dozens of
papers and reports to give you the best
snapshot I can on llms and AI more
broadly I'm going to start I'm afraid
with so much of what's wrong with the
current landscape from delayed releases
overpromises and my biggest current
concern a tragedy of the commons from AI
slop but then I will caution those who
might throw the baby out with the bath
water giving six detailed evidence-based
pathways from the llms we have today to
substantially more powerful and useful
models including systems that yes
perform decently even on that abstract
reasoning challenge I showed you earlier
but let's start with the dodgy stuff in
quote Ai and no I'm not referring to the
fact that the creators and funders of
this Ark AGI challenge are so confident
that current generation LMS cannot
succeed that they've put up a prize pool
of over a million doar if GPT 40 was a
pure reasoning engine well then why is
its performance negligible in this
challenge but no I'm actually referring
to the landscape of over promising and
underd delivering you might remember
Demis cabis referring to the original
Gemini model when it was launched as
being as good as human experts but
Google has had to roll back its llm
powered AI overview feature because
there were simply far too many mistakes
if Gemini was as good as human experts
as some some benchmarks were claiming to
show then why wouldn't it be better than
a random Google search but surely the
newly announced Apple intelligence will
be far better though well aside from the
fact that we can't actually test it no
Tim Cook admitted that it still
hallucinates all the time now to some as
we'll see that's actually the point of
llms we want them to be creative but to
others it smells more like BS this
particular paper aside from being quite
funny gave one clear take-home message
language models aren't actually designed
to be correct they aren't designed to
transmit information so don't be
surprised when their assertions turn out
to be false of course people are working
on that and the paper even makes
reference to the let's verify
step-by-step paper more on that later
but the point remains so we have the
hallucinations in Ai and then the
hallucinations in the marketing about Ai
and the fact that we have ai powered
toothbrushes isn't even my primary
concern and nor is it actually that we
occasionally have those wildly overhyped
products like the rabbit R1 and the
Humane AI pin then there's the possible
breaches in privacy that features like
Microsoft recall seem to inevitably
invite I don't know about you but it was
never appealing to me to have an llm
analyze screenshots taken of my desktop
every few seconds imagine the poor llm
trying to sift through all of the
Creations that some are likely to come
up with using open AI tools you might
think I've reached the end of my dodgy
list but I'm not actually even close
what about the increase in academics
using llms to write or polish papers you
can see the recent and dramatic increase
in the use of the word delve on papers
on PubMed for me as soon as I suspect an
article I'm reading is llm generated I
just discount it heavily then we get the
delayed releases now this one is
arguably a bit more forgivable but we
were promised GPT 40 within a few weeks
I think we all would prefer a tradition
when features are announced the moment
they're actually available I will come
back to GPT 40 in a moment now you might
be different but for me the number one
concern at the moment is just AI
generated slop take this tool where on
LinkedIn you can imitate the writing of
someone in your field or industry are
they going viral while you get little to
no engagement copy their tone and
address the same topic and I would call
this a kind of tragedy of the commons
for the individuals using this and I'm
not meaning to pick on one individual
tool but for the individuals using this
it's probably pretty helpful it probably
does Boost engagement and help sort out
any language issues but as we've seen of
late on Facebook it just leads to this
General AI generated miasma Bots
engaging with Bots gullible people drawn
in and fooled a landscape where
increasing L you can't trust what you
see or even hear and that's before even
getting to the topic of deep fakes which
of course can acutely affect the
individuals concerned you can of course
let me know if you agree but for me this
is at the moment the number one concern
and it's hard to see how it would be
stopped at this point you're probably
thinking damn this is pretty negative on
AI but as you can see the video has
plenty of time to go but at this point
my rejoiner to sum is that it's all too
easy to fall into diametrically opposed
camps as we saw last year with
accelerationists and doomers we're
seeing this year with those who say AI
is nothing but hype and those who say
AGI is imminent but I think the world is
just so much more complex than that I
reckon that if I was blind I would
forgive the occasional hallucination
with GPT 40 and be grateful to have a
model that can tell me about the World
Around Me Oh and interactively and in
real time and tell me exactly what
they're doing right now please um right
now the Ducks are gently gliding across
the water they're moving in a fairly
relaxed manner not in a hurry
occasionally one of them will get its
head under the water probably looking
for food and then pop back
up I even know when a taxi is coming
with its orange light on I think I'll
hail it to get
home yes I spotted one just now it's
heading away on the left side of the
road get ready to wave it
[Music]
down great job hailing that taxi it
looks like you're all set to go that's a
good dog right there leading the way
into the taxi safe travels and remember
too that as project Astra from Google
demonstrated models are getting better
at ingesting more and more tokens more
and more context they are increasingly
able to help users of any kind locate
things not just in text but in the real
world now we'll get back to llms in a
moment but of course it's worth
remembering that there are far more to
neural networks than just llms a new
study in nature showed how you could use
Gans generative adversarial networks to
predict the effects of untested
chemicals on mice gen AI in this case
was able to simulate a virtual animal
experiment to generate profiles similar
to those obtained from traditional
animal studies the tldd is not just that
the Gen predictions had less error but
they were produced much more quickly and
as the BBC reported this is at least one
tentative step toward an end to animal
testing and yes that study was different
to this one released a few days ago with
Harvard and Google deepmind where they
built a virtual rodent powered by AI
again a highly realistic simulation but
this time down to the level of neural
activity inside those real rats then of
course we have the good old con
evolutional neural networks for image
analysis their use in the brainix E
stroke system is as we speak helping
stroke victims in the NHS essentially it
has enabled diagnosis to be made by
clinicians much more quickly which in
the case of Strokes is super important
of course and that has tripled the
number of patients recovering now the
only tiny tiny complaint I would make is
that as ever the title just uses the
phrase AI it took me a disturbing amount
of digging to track down the actual
technique te used and even then of
course for commercial reasons they don't
say everything but now I want to return
to large language models the central
focus of this channel now I have
discussed in the past on this channel
some of the reasoning gaps that you can
find in current generation large
language models but the arc abstract
reasoning Challenge and prize publicized
this week by the legendary franois
charet is a great opportunity to clarify
what exactly are current models Miss and
what is being done to rectify that Gap
hopefully at least the following will
explain in part why our models can
sometimes be shockingly dumb and
shockingly smart I'm going to leave in
the background for a minute an example
of the kind of challenge that models
like gp4 fail at consistently so here is
in 60 seconds what the current issue is
if language models haven't seen a
solution to something in their training
data they won't be able to give you a
solution when you test them that's why
models fail at this challenge they
simply haven't seen these tests before
moreover the models aren't generally
intelligent you can train them on
millions of these kind of examples and
people have tried and they'll still fail
on a new Fresh one again if that new
fresh example isn't in the training data
set they will fail if the mother of
Gabriel Mack is in the data set they
will output the correct answer if
however the data son of that suzan
Victoria pulia is not in the data set it
will not know it doesn't reason its way
to the answer based on other parts of
its training data so how can models do
so well on certain benchmarks like the
math benchmark well they can quote
recall from their training data set
certain reasoning chains that they've
seen before that's enough in certain
circumstances to get the answer right so
hang on a second they can recall certain
reasoning procedures let's call them
programs but they can't create them yes
it's a good news bad news kind of
situation but for the remainder of this
video indeed for the remainder of llms
it will be important to remember that
distinction recalling reasoning
procedures or programs versus doing
fresh reasoning itself if it's seen it
before great if it hasn't seen it before
not so great okay so we're almost ready
for those six ways which might drag llms
closer to that artificial general
intelligence but first I want to quickly
focus on one thought you may have had in
reaction to this framework why not train
language models on every reasoning
procedure out there feed it data on any
scenario it might encounter and wouldn't
that be AGI well here's franois sh the
author of The Ark challenge he'll
explain why memorization isn't enough
because we don't don't see the whole map
if the world if your life were a static
distribution uh then sure you could just
Brute Force the space of possible
behaviors you can think of intelligence
as a paast finding algorithm in future
situation space like I don't know if
you're familiar with scam development
like RTS gam development but you have a
map right and and you have it's like a
2d 2D 2D map and um you have partial
information about it there is some fog
of War on your map there are areas that
you haven't explored yet you know
nothing about them and then there are
areas that you've explored but um you
only know how they were like in the past
and and now instead of thinking about to
I think about the space of possible
future situations that you might
encounter and how they're connected to
each other intelligence is a past
finding algorithm so once you set a goal
it will tell you uh how to get there
optimally um but of course it's it's
constrained by the information you have
it it cannot pass F in an area that you
know nothing about if you had complete
information about the map then you could
solve the pathf finding Problem by
simply memorizing every possible path
every mapping from a point A to point B
solve the problem with pure memory but
where the reason you cannot do that in
real life is because you don't actually
know what's going to happen in the
future so if AI will be encountering
novel situations it will need to adapt
on the Fly what would make me change my
mind about that Al is basically if I
start seeing a critical mass of cases
where you show the model with something
it has not seen before a task that's
actually novel from the perspective of
its training data something that's not
in a training data if it can actually
adapt on the Fly and that might be more
possible than you think as gnome Brown
of open AI thinks he's optimistic that
llms will crack it but again it won't be
just a naive scaling up of data that
alone gets us there without examples or
zero shot as we've seen models don't
generalize from what they've seen to
what they haven't this paper
demonstrates that in the visual domain
as we've already seen it in the text
domain no matter what neural network
architecture or parameter scale they
tested models were data hungry unlike a
human child they didn't learn in a
sample efficient manner remember that a
child might be shown one image of a
camel with the caption camel and retain
that term for life however Midway
through the paper there there was some
tentative evidence that with enough
scale you can get decent results on
rarely found Concepts those were
represented by the let it wag data set
referring to the long tail of a
distribution anyway as you can see
models that performed at over 80% on
this traditional well-known image net
accuracy test did perform fairly well on
this longtail data set as they note the
Gap in performance does seem to be
decreasing for higher capacity model in
other words more data definitely helps
especially exponentially more data but
it definitely won't be enough but even
this paper pointed to some ways that
this challenge might be overcome they
note possibilities for not only
retrieval mechanisms but compositional
generalization in other words piecing
together Concepts that have been found
in the training data set to be able to
recognize more complex ones and if you
think that's impossible I've got news
for you in a moment just before I do
though I want to get to one other
approach that I don't think will work
you may or may not have heard on the
Twitter sphere about the situational
awareness 165 page report put out by a
former open aai researcher I've done a
full 45 minute breakdown on my patreon
AI insiders but one key takeaway is this
he thinks the straight march to AGI will
be achieved by scaling up the parameters
and data of our current llms but again I
think that's far far too simplistic just
throwing on more parameters and more
data wouldn't resolve the kind of issues
you've seen today Leopold Ashen brener
also made some other somewhat crazier
claims but that's for this video so it's
time to get to the first of those six
methods that I mentioned that might drag
llms closer to something we might call a
general intelligence and this paper
published late last year in nature is
about that compositionality I mentioned
just a moment ago perhaps models can't
reason but if they can better compose
reasoning blocks into something more
complex might that be enough well the
authors prove that point in principle at
least on just a 1.4 million parameter
Transformer based model boldly they
claim our results show how a standard
noral Network architecture optimized for
its compositional skills can mimic human
systematic generalization in a
head-to-head comparison and as the lead
author of the paper retweeted the answer
to better AI is probably not just more
training data but rather diversifying
training strategies tldr send the robot
to algebra class every so often and the
challenge as you can see in the bottom
left was this it might even remind you a
little bit of the arc challenge the
challenge was to work out what this
madeup language fragment actually meant
based on these rules given enough time
humans tend to do fairly well at this
challenge like the arc challenge but
models like GPT 4 as we'll see flop hard
remember GPT 4 has 1.8 trillion
parameters versus the model they trained
at 1.4 million anyway with enough time
in your case and training in the case of
their Transformer model it worked out
that for example who means to whereas s
means green and re means light blue
there are other rules to work out of
course and then those rules have to be
composed together to work out the
question answer now remember when they
were tested they were tested on a new
configuration of words they had to quote
understand the madeup rules of a new
language and apply them to phrases it
hadn't been trained on it was able to do
so in other words show the first
tentative hints at true reasoning it's
only a very small step towards AGI
though because when they tested these
flickers of compositional reasoning on a
new task this tiny model failed okay
time for the next approach if as we've
seen language models have these
reasoning chains or programs within them
to solve challenges they're just hard to
find what about methods that improve our
ability to find those programs within
language models that's what in part
verifies our about a string of papers
came out this week about using verifiers
and Monte Carlo treesearch to improve
the mathematical reasoning of language
models of course covering all of them
would be a video in and of itself but in
a nutshell it's about this you can train
a model to recognize faulty steps in a
reasoning chain to pick out the bad
programs with let's verify step by step
which I've talked about many times
before on this channel that required
human annotation but Google deepmind
came up with approach which was done in
an automated fashion by automatically
collecting results which led to a
correct answer as well as contrasting
them with outputs that led to an
incorrect output they trained a process
reward model think of it like a
supervisor analyzing each step of a
language model's outputs or to use the
analogy we've been using throughout this
video the process reward model could
alert the language model the moment it's
calling a faulty or inappropriate
program in theory but at least in this
paper there is a limit to this approach
even when analyzing and deciding amongst
over a 100 Solutions the performance
started to Plateau for sure it's still a
huge boost on this math benchmark from
50% to around 70% but there's a limit is
that because it's not using human
annotation like with let's verify or is
it a fundamental limitation with the
approach perhaps if a language model
doesn't have the requisite program in
its training data set to solve a math
problem it can't do so no matter what
supervision it's given nevertheless the
principle is clearly established we
don't have to rely on the language model
itself locating the correct and
necessary program to solve a challenge
we can at least help it along the way
and we know that there are even better
verifiers out there namely simulations
and the real world as I discussed with
Jason Mah the lead author of The Dr
Eureka paper it's a feature because that
means the LM can sample let's say a 100
different solutions and your simulator
in this case serves as external verifier
to see which ones are good if your LM
doesn't have the ability to hallucinate
it's always deterministic then the
method will actually not work because
you would only be able to generate one
candidate per iteration right so it
becomes very slow every time the model
generates any response it's technically
hallucinating it just a sample from the
probability distribution right and it's
only hallucination if it doesn't agree
with what you think it should output
right but in my case is I don't care if
it agrees with what I think is a good
reward I have something external to
verify so it's great the model can
output a 100 different things that makes
the iterative evolutionary process much
faster so I think that's actually a
blessing that I think if you only think
about applications like chatbot agents
you may underappreciate but if you think
about the use case for large language
models or any foundation model for I
think Discovery tasks or scientific
discoveries what you want is the model
to be able to propose 10 different
solutions is it possible that we can
turn hallucinations from a weakness to a
strength Nvidia and others are of course
working hard to find out that second
approach then can be summed up as using
verifiers and other approach is to
better locate the requisite programs
within a large language model and I will
quickly mention another method for
locating that latent knowledge many shot
give models tons and tons of examples of
the kind of task you want it to achieve
and it can better learn how to do so it
seems obvious but it can lead to
significant performance gains but what
about teaching language models new
programs on the Fly this is what franois
Chalet calls active inference and it's
responsible for the current state
of-the-art score of 34% on the ark AGI
prize there are many facets to this
approach but I'm going to summarize
heavily the key Insight is to use test
time fine-tuning when the model sees
three examples like those on the left
that isn't enough to teach it the way to
solve the fourth one it's too minuscule
a signal amongst all its many parameters
but one of the things that Jack Cole and
code did is augment these three examples
with many many synthetic examples that
mimic the style they then fine-tune the
model on those augmented examples I
think of it as prioritizing as humans do
the thing right in front of its face you
can almost think of it like a language
model concentrating its parameters are
adjusted to focus on the task at hand a
bit like a human going into the Flow by
the way they also use gp4 to generate
many of the synthetic riddles to train
their system here's how franois charet
describes the approach most of the time
when you're when you're using an llm
it's just doing static inference the
model is frozen and you're just uh
prompting it and then you're get you're
getting an answer so the model is not
actually learning anything on the Fly
it's its state is not adapting to the to
the task at hand and what jao is
actually doing is that for every test
problem is on the Fly is fine tune in a
version of d llm uh for that task and
that's really what's unlocking
performance if you don't do that you get
like 1% two % so basically something
completely completely negligible and if
you do test time fine tuning and you add
a bunch of tricks on top then you end up
with interesting performance numbers so
I think what he's doing is trying to
address one of the key limitations of
LMS today uh which is the lack of active
inference is actually adding active
Insurance to LMS and that's working
extremely well actually so that's
fascinating to me in sure even on the
Achilles heel of large language models
abstract reasoning Jack Cole says this
what is clear from our work and from
others is that the upper limits of the
capabilities of llms even small ones
have not yet been discovered by the way
his model is just 240 million parameters
there is clear evidence that more
generally capable models are possible
again sticking with the program metaphor
as franois Chalet says this is like
doing program synthesis another
definition we can use is reasoning is
the ability to when you're faced with a
with a puzzle given that you don't have
already a program in memory to solve it
you must synthesize on the fly a new
program based on bits of pieces of
existing programs that you have you have
to do on the Fly program synthesis and
it's actually dramatically harder than
just fetching the right memorized
program and replying it now at this
point in the video as we get to the
fourth approach I'm going to make a
confession I have about 20 tabs left on
my screen going over other relevant
papers on how they improve llms but I am
beginning to worry that this video might
be getting a little bit too long so for
the last few approaches I'm going to be
much more brief I hope I'm still
conveying that Central message though
that llms currently suck at abstract
reasoning but that need not be a death
sentence nothing in the literature
indicates that AGI is at all imminent
but neither is AI all hype here is a
paper from the arch llm skeptic
Professor raal who I interviewed almost
a year ago it's a position paper from
this week lm's C plan but can help
planning in llm modulo Frameworks we had
a great discussion almost a year ago
which I'll hopefully get to in a
different video but the summary of this
paper is this earlier work by professor
raal and Co had shown that even models
like gp4 can't come up with coherent
plans they fail in this domain of bloxs
world essentially bloxs world is like
some of the other reasoning challenges
you've seen today in that you have to
come up with a coherent plan unstacking
blocks and restacking them to meet the
required objective definitely not a
memorization test as the MML U can
sometimes be indeed if you throw off the
model and use mysterious words instead
of household objects the models perform
even worse zero shot gp4 gets one out of
600 challenges however this fourth
approach says why do we have to use llms
alone why can't we use them with
traditional symbolic systems maybe that
combination of neural networks and
traditional symbolic hardcoded
programmatic systems is better than
either alone Professor raal is a friend
of yan Lun a famed llm skeptic but the
paper that he led said this there is
unwarranted pessimism about the roles
llms can play in planning SL reasoning
tasks the key Insight is that llms can
act as idea generators those grounded
symbolic systems can then check those
plans llms as the ideas man
with symbolic systems as the kind of
accountants llms are great at guessing
candidate plans to solve bloxs World
challenges and those ideas or you could
say retrieve programs aren't all bad
even after three or four rounds of
feedback from the symbolic system 50% of
the final plan retains the elements of
the initial large language model plan
with that feedback from the symbolic
system you back prompt the llm and it
comes up with hopefully a better plan
not even hopefully though the results
are clear GPT 4 can score 82% with this
approach still struggles with mysterious
languages but can solve five of them
this all reminded me of alpha geometry
which I have done a separate video on so
I won't focus on today but it's that
same combination of a neural network and
symbolic system for geometry problems
specifically in the international math
Olympiad it scored almost a gold medal
those are incredibly hard reasoning
challenges very quickly now the fifth
approach instead of calling a separate
system how about jointly training on its
knowledge for time purposes here is a
very quick summary they trained a
separate neural network not a language
model in this case a graph neural
network it learned specialized
algorithms then they embedded that fixed
optimized knowhow and had a language
model train with access to those
embeddings in other words a language
model fluent in the language of text and
algorithms programs that you might need
for example for sorting six and finally
for this video there's tacit data so
much of what humans do and how humans
reason is not written down let's hear
from Terren to arguably the smartest man
on the planet he said so much knowledge
is somehow trapped in the head of
individual mathematicians and only a
tiny fraction is made explicit A lot of
the intuition of mathematicians is not
captured in the printed papers in
journals but in conversations among
mathematicians in lectures and in the
way we advise students people only
publish the success stories the data
that are really precious are from when
someone tries something and it doesn't
quite work but they know how to fix it
but they only publish the successful
thing not the process and all of this he
says simultaneously points to a dramatic
way to improve AI but also why we
shouldn't expect an intelligence
explosion imminently training on that
tacet data would unlock notable progress
but human mathematicians he says
would just in his view move to a higher
type of mathematics as we speak open Ai
and I'm sure many others are trying to
make as explicit as possible that tacit
knowledge I'm sure hundreds of phds are
writing down their methodologies as they
solve problems Millions if not billions
of YouTube hours of video are being
ingested in the hopes that AI models
pick up some of that implicit reasoning
while you may see this as the most
promising approach of the six I've so
far mentioned it wouldn't yield
immediate explosive results it would be
reliant on us and other human experts to
write down with Fidelity our reasoning
less a remorseless faceless shogo
solving the universe and more a student
imitating its teachers of course you
will have likely seen the somewhat
ambiguous clip from Mira murati the CTO
of open aai saying they don't have any
giant breakthrough behind the scenes
inside the labs we have the these
capable models and you know they're not
that far ahead from what the public has
access to for free and that's a
completely different trajectory for
bringing technology into the world that
what we've seen historically but as I've
hopefully shown you today it doesn't
have to be an all or nothing AGI
imminently or all hype as even franois
Chalet says it could be a combination of
approaches that solves for example Ark
that indeed might be the path to AGI
people are going to be uh winning uh the
AR competition and that we're going to
be making the most progress towards near
term are going to be S that manage to
merge the Deep planning Paradigm and a
discret for search Paradigm into one
elegant way so much more to get to that
I couldn't get to today but I hope this
video has helped you to navigate the
current AI landscape as ever the world
is more complex than it seems thank you
so much as ever for watching and have a
wonderful day